I mean it is of course a high-wire act
it so his maximum pressure because you
can't prepare yourself really I mean you
do prepare yourself you look at the
seating plan you study very carefully
who has expressed interest in which work
but of course there is no script you
know how it's going to do and then you
have to improvise and what you try and
do is an auctioneer is really great
excitement create make it fun make it
amusing even for people who are there
just to watch it you want it to be
entertaining it's so that's you make it
as lively as possible you change the
wisdom the way you put the sails
together also has a big influence I mean
you you have strong moments lesser
moments and you have to put it together
like like a theatre play with so all of
that is part of it now like every artist
like every person there you have good
days and sometimes less good days
sometimes you're in better shape than in
others but you try even if things were
not going as well as you would hope to
to remain cheerful and positive and not
to then you know pass on a feeling of
gloom to your audience
you